bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti ha messo
loro sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul
secondo episodio di immagini illustro
brevemente perché non conosce la cosa
anzi era e forse era meglio così tempo
fa ragazzi circolavano sul web delle
deleghe racconti erotici su di me
se mi veniva talmente tanto da ridere a
leggere queste cose che che ho dovuto
farci invito sopra partiamo con la
seconda serie di racconti su immaginare
vj o queste fino a queste [ __ ] lorenzo
il tuo compagno di classe ti accompagna
a casa e ti chiede di salire su
ovviamente per non essere maleducata
dici di sì ma quando vai vuoi salire
tesoro sì magari dalla chiesto un
vecchio di 80 anni tool pro non essere
maleducata dici sì no che non dicessi ma
che cazzo dici se io domani vado in giro
a chiedere alle tp a caso prima di
venire a casa mia l'ativa deve dirmi di
sì non può dirmi di no perché sono è
maleducata io ci provo adesso non è così
ti denuncio salite in casa e ti
abbraccia dicendo che ti ha sempre a
nata tu sempre per non essere scortese
diceva bene vi baciate vi mettete
insieme sempre per non essere scortese
fate anche dei bambini giusto per non
essere scortese sai che ho chiesto di fa
sesso non puoi dirmi di no ogni giorno
di lascia un bigliettino che scritta ti
amo è una margherita sul tuo banco prima
di venire in classe la mattina una
margherita si intende alla pizza è c'è
perché non posso essere scortese se
chiedo al pizzaiolo una margherita alle
6 del mattino crei viviamo questa è
bella che son nudo un santo dio credi di
essere in casa da sola e decidi di farti
un bagno la vasca è stranamente già
piena e proprio mentre ti rilassi sì
perché certo vedi la vasca già piena e
dc cazzo che bello la masca è piena come
fa a essere piena ma si facciamoci un
bagno magari entrato un killer l'ha
aperta l'acqua della vasca è piena ma
tutti fa il bagno così proprio mentre ti
rilassi senti le labbra di lorenzo
sbloccare le tue secondo me era meglio
al ladro si sussurra l'acqua un po
fredda ma la ri scalderemo
e così e partono le coltellate piene di
sangue vedi come si riscalda immagina
rosso porca [ __ ] tutti rossi lorenzo
siete nello stesso gruppo di canto v che
io so cantare da dio e la prof propone
le coppie per i duetti 2 lorenzo siete
insieme tu e lui sapete che sei un
soprano voce più alta
lorenzo ti porta nello sgabuzzino e ti
prende per i fianchi facendoti scegliere
sul calorifero valori a riti si avvicina
all'orecchio mentre inizia a sfogliare
film il pranzo
fammi sentire quanto sei tirare in alto
gli acuti piccoli oppure potrebbe essere
semplicemente un urlo accompagnato dalla
polizia che arriva dipende dai punti di
vista passiamo al prossimo ragazzi sei
fidanzata con lorenzo da qualche mese
così decide di farti conoscere i suoi
genitori per farti sapere la tua
decisione ti manda questa foto con
scritto i tuoi futuri suoceri non vedono
l'ora di conoscerti mia madre cia la
espressione proprio come se stesse per
dire perché mio figlio stanno
assaggiando con un atto di cenni e mamma
sono cose che non potresti mai capire
immagini su famiglia e tu e lori avete
una figlia alla madonna già avanzata
questa figlia due punti perché io mia
figlia la chiamavo figlia anche il mio
cane lo chiamo provocando i papà ma la
mamma sta male
no perchè stanotte l'ho sentita che
urlava il tuo nome avrà avuto un incubo
se la figlia si chiama figlia il cane si
chiama cane il mio nome e marito
immaginati una che orgasm a di notte
grida parli tu e il tuo amico lorenzo
siete in banca per prelevare quando
arrivano cinque ladri che scatenano
subito il panico puntando le pistole
contro di voi e le altre persone c'è chi
urla
c'è chi cerca di scappare chi è
spaventato e che immobilizzato lorenzo
cerca di farti coraggio tirando tia se e
stringendo t con un braccio ad un certo
punto un ladro prende qualche ostaggio
ma quando cerca di prendere anche te
lorenzo ti stringe più forte dicendo
all'uomo prova solo a toccarlo a farle
del male che ti ammazzo se devi prendere
qualcuno prendi me
buongiorno ragazzi io sono il nuovo
professore di pensaci tu il mio nome
vladimir putin 2 lui molte volte vi
scambiate nelle occhiatine durante la
lezione è flirtate spesso nel corridoio
tu non riesci più a studiare perché ti
sei innamorata di lui un giorno ti porta
in bagno e ti sbatte contro il muro vuoi
distruggere prima isis o turchia
fla di silenzio o di spedire in siberia
bellissima la più bella finora stupenda
poi con l'occhiolino
no no questa non la leggo non la
vogliono e non lo sai camminando per
strada quando a un certo punto ti
scontri con uno sconosciuto ma ti
accorgi subito che lui è il tuo idolo di
amore erotico segreto fa vj
i vostri occhi si incrociano e la
scintilla scatta scusami ti dice tu
invece lo guardi con occhi sognanti
che ne dici per scusarmi di aver portato
di venire a casa mia così vedi come me
la cavo e più per non essere scortese
nel caso di sfondo accetti
immediatamente sapendo che già il tuo
sogno si sta per avverare arrivati a
casa lui ti fa sedere sul suo divano vi
guardate intensamente all'improvviso lui
tira fuori il suo joystick e te lo da
stai tremando non riesce a crederci
stai giocando a cat mario con famiglie
grazie gesù pensavo peggio
la prima volta nella vita che sono
contento di leggere una trovata ma la
prima proprio se vogliamo proprio essere
puntigliosi che mario non si gioca col
joyce ma va bene va bene così anzi
preferisco gesù che cazzo questa ragazza
è gialla quindi è una via di mezzo
se in piscina con i tuoi amici hanno un
certo punto ti accorgi di un ragazzo
molto carino bruno che ti guarda cerchi
di far finta di niente ma proprio non ci
riesce e tu ami che ti dicono di andare
da lui e tu l'hai ascolti ma ciao
piccola certo è ovvio come incipit è
perfetto per rimorchiare
certo lo sai che sei molto carina tu
invece di correre alla polizia dice beh
grazie
dopo un po ti dal suo numero di
cellulare e ti invita a casa sua al
giorno dopo sarete da soli però
sei a casa del tuo amico lorenzo perché
ti ha invitato ad una festa ma quando
arrivi vedi solo lui ti dice ti amo e
poi ti butta sul letto era tra gli
invitati c'erano sono tutti nascosti
negli armadi che che stanno guardando
chi cazzo succede
ma poi perché con questa foto ma perché
mai immaginati l'atto sessuale con le
lame di wolverine ma come cazzo è così
come faccio scritto vabbè non sto
scherzando non voglio dire questa cosa
santo iddio finalmente il giorno più
bello della tua vita è arrivato il
giorno in cui sposerai lorenzo che gioia
manca qualche ora prima che la cerimonia
inizi e lui per augurarti buona giornata
ti manda questa foto su whatsapp non
vedo l'ora di vederti entrare dentro la
chiesa più bella che mai solo per me nel
nostro giorno più bello ti amo era la
scusa ho sbagliato il destinatario
volevo era un'altra la tipa da bestie
gas tra il tuo fidanzato lori avete
deciso di trovarmi in un bar per stare
un po insieme ma lui è in ritardo dopo
un'ora di attesa decidi di andartene ma
proprio in quel momento arriva lori
scusa ma ora c'è voluto tutto questo
tempo per trovare il migliore
qui ti s'inginocchia davanti prende un
piccolo cofanetto contenente un anello
con soffrono diamante e ti dice vuoi
sposarmi o brutto [ __ ] se arrivate
in ritardo ma [ __ ]
poi ci ho messo tanto per trovare il
diamante anche sondato nega verne tipo
minecraft è il primo giorno di scuola e
appena entri tutti di saluto noti che
c'è un nuovo alunno così decide di
sedersi vicino a lui iniziate a parlare
a scherzare e scopri che si chiama
lorenzo dopo circa un mesetto ormai
siete diventati molto amici giorno ti
dice che vorrebbe parlarti e durante
l'intervallo ti porta in una stanza con
solo voi due e ti sbatte contro il muro
un istante dopo apre la bidella si trova
lì così siamo condannati a fare gli
spazzini per il resto della nostra vita
è per concludere in bellezza ragazzi
pollino rosso immagina vuoi è un orgasmo
sentiro questo se fatevi dei fazzoletti
set ecco allora che sony concludo che
l'episodio perché santo dio ma proprio
no
grazie per aver scritto queste cose mi
avete migliorato la giornata di non so
quanto spero che lascerete tutto mi
piace perché sennò di mandare in siberia
spero che video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
cascade subito piaciuto affatto un
commento
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e con i video tra tale
iscrizione
insieme ai cibi è perché mi sono
emozionato ce l'ho duro e mi è caduto
senza vestiti chiari ci vediamo al
prossimo vito avariarsi
[Musica]